si fa chi è un gioco che non è non fa
gli spaventi bella tutti ragazzi
pervenute questo nuovo giorno di nuova
influenza di [ __ ] siamo sul gioco
che non so se non ricordate quel gioco
bello dove ci sta questo tizio bello la
grafica bella in poche parole ragazze
hanno fatto la storia o di gioco quindi
the joy of creation che belli questi
uomini
a parte la bellezza estetica di questi
uomini volevo dirvi che la story mode di
questo videogame mi alletta un sacco
quindi il living room dem
credo che in realtà non ho idea di che
cosa ci sia di diverso visto che il
primo videogame di questo non son
riuscito manco a finirlo perché era
difficile però salve
buongiorno ricordatevi con l'influenza
quindi non fate gli stronzi anche chi fa
ok
ma che cazzo a mano ma non mi muovo
clicco figo uno solo non avevo capito
bello dove cazzo vado quindi io no
ma ma sei tu non c'è bisogno della
tachipirina sto bene con la coperta ho
detto che non c'è bisogno che lo sapevo
samara a non uscire dal televisore
grazie
c'è un modo per vincere questa roba da
prendervi solo infatti finché non gli va
bene al gioco bene il divano illuminato
e bellissimo si può fare se vissuta
qualcosa me ne vado non è che salto non
è che salta dalla sedia me ne vado
proprio cosa devo fare a parte questo
non mi posso muovere se non scendere dal
divano e risalire complimenti zio che
atletica fratelli miei cosa devo fare a
parte fissare il televisore che si apre
la porta sono morto se non posso fargli
scopo politico non riesce neanche a
muoversi
guarda che problemi cui solo scendere e
salire dal divano casa e bambino cioè le
gambe e si o no no no non fare questa
cosa non fare questa bene così
vorrei potermi girare man un'idea di
come fare fantastico bene
turn over trolio petrolio ma [ __ ]
survived due minuti verne male pensavo
peggio
si può rifare bello fantastico quindi mi
fate capire il coi comandi vi prego
iddio non ho capito quindi io posso
cliccare sulle cose e andare sulle cose
perché dovrei
quindi ti butta la nonna figata non
avevo capito quindi ios e clicco col
sinistro torni indietro
va bene no non fa cagare grazie
il fai vedere cosa c'è dietro la porta
non lo vogliamo sapere accendi la luce
perfect poste posso andare anche
supposte
sotto di dio state calmi jesus e clicco
sul televisore comunque non fa niente
tranne nascondersi dietro il divano che
potrebbe essere utile quando quando apro
questa porta fantastico però credo sia
ancora più utile puntarci la torcia
quindi questa ok la porta qui è ok posso
sbirciare la serratura o fai cose salve
un giorno e va bene arrivederci
questo devo fare torno mi ha fatto il
ministro solito veloce veloce loss
difatti capire una roba nagaoka ho
capito che c'è il tizio dito la porta ma
come lo levo da dietro la porta
c'è un comando ecco posso fare un cazzo
non posso prendermi sono infatti finché
non muoio bello sto gioco bello bello
epic games 2016
un minuto e 46 cazzo come sono
migliorato avere ragazzi li proviamo
comunque io vi voglio dire una roba che
credo ve ne siate accorti tutti è andata
e provati con lo stesso tratto i giochi
horror che io abbia mai fatto da quando
ho aperto il canale credo che the joker
questo gioco bello di nome sia uno dei
più difficili della storia e non ho mai
fatto un gioco horror così difficile
perché l'unico videogame horror che non
riesco a fare cioè non escono andare
oltre
muoio in condizioni stupide anche
provandoci riprovandoci assicuro che non
supererà mai 2000 non arrivano mai a tre
minuti di sopravvivenza in sta roba lo
so io me lo sento
che bella sostanza tra l'altro mi chiave
incantevole non si può aprire la porta
in qualche modo tipo non va bene che mi
interessasse va bene così la radio ok
niente quindi posso guardare le
serrature mandare indietro capitan
uncino guardare the ring attraverso
l'amore bruttissimo via via via via
veloce accendi ok
che cazzo e con la roma rossa 9 non lo
voglio scoperto e torna indietro
indietro indietro indietro perfetto bene
posso farvi una domanda ma molti voli
che stanza è di preciso cosa mi sta
mostrando sto televisore in realtà in
tutti i file nettv reddito roba del
genere si vedono gli animatronics dentro
un computer se tu capisci dove suona
riesce a prevederli ma qua non si
capisce se che cazzo adesso televisore
cosa mi sta mostrando su david ok mi sta
mostrando l'ultima puntata di don matteo
preferibile domate ma sta roba molto
preferibile grazie sbirci cazzo cazzo
cazzo cazzo cascato dentro veloce veloce
veloce velocissimo
oddio oh mio dio vi ritorna torna alla
porta ok benz viaccia piacere fa vj
facciamo così io torno sul divano credo
di star bene sul divano comodo questo
divano mi nascondo di mortacci tua di
tua madre frottola di quella [ __ ] in
autostrada prendere buttare nei tombini
bavera gare c'è io farò due minuti a 40
comunque tre minuti in mango buca posso
farvi la domanda vi prego iddio
a cosa serve sto divano cosa a cosa
serve fare questa cosa che sto facendo
scendo e guardo il divano a cosa mi
serve cosa
girati [ __ ] e che cazzo non ce la
posso vari cazzo di videogame ogni volta
il divano e meravigliosa sta cosa che
faccio per scendere dal divano è
devastante sto gioco proprio è proprio
un gioco bello stavo solo scherzando mi
piace giocare a sta roba
infatti capire obama l'ha lui si spengo
la luce del soggiorno fosse spegne il
televisore che cazzo chi è
l'elettricista qualla piano ho detto
piano d'uscita tito non teniamo sotto
controllo le porte non c'è un timer che
almeno vedo un record secondo me i
ragazzi sto gioco non si può finire non
c'è un punto in cui ti fanno l'applauso
e finisce la notte non esiste questo è
un gioco solo per perdere però devo
battere il mio record sito e se stessi
guardando un porno e tu entri così le
false domande al piano successo no dai
non ci credo ma far nulla forge a ceva
peccato pensavo potessi fare qualcosa
due minuti e 40 di nuovo ma dai raga non
si può fare più di due minuti a 41
impossibile può fare solo due minuti e
40 e basta poi non puoi fare più niente
bello questo gioco è meraviglio
soprattutto quando non stai bene
fisicamente giocare astra battini piglia
che minchia brodo di pollo spostati va
bè ragazzi ultimo tentativo proviamo ad
andare sopra i due minuti e 40 proviamo
è meglio assicura niente è una cosa che
vorrei tanto avere che non ho questo
poster c'è il posto archi cep di fi nate
tre dischi vedo ovunque in tutti i
fottuti giochi di file nights lo vedo
vorrei appendere meli in camera solo per
il gusto di chiudermi la porta a chiave
dire [ __ ] era difficile perché se
questo cristiano chiudesse le porta a
chiave sarebbe a posto sarebbe a parte
non sono anche come ci sei arrivato tu
studi vanno da
chiamano neanche capito perché in realtà
sei un nano da giardino e non arrivino
anche a guardare oltre il divano quello
è un altro discorso però in generale a
parte che sei arrivato qua parte che sei
un nano dovresti almeno chiudere la
porta a chiave c'è non è difficile zio
tracciava che berruto in culo come
faccio a sopravvivere cosa devo fare per
sopravvivere
mi stavo dicendo ragazzi che fino ad ora
sono morto ma non nessuno ha aperto
porte o cose del genere solo questa e ho
tempestivamente risposto chiudendo
mi piacciono i tuoi gioielli di famiglia
sono proprio belli arrivato lo so che
arriva già non lo sento
cosa devo fare per evitarlo non c'è non
sta succedendo mi capitana [ __ ] parto
bruttissimo due minuti e quaranta
famiglie minare noi 26 26
niente ragazzi due minuti e 40 in questo
gioco sono insuperabili proprio gioco
difficile progaming non fa vj
sicuramente perché c'era tipo una roba
nelle opzioni tipo avrei deficienti che
non sanno giocare cliccate qua e vincete
non c'è stazione pero ragazzi che questo
video vi sia piaciuto spero che abbiate
capito meglio di me come si gioca sta
roba perché io veramente non ho capito
un cazzo ma niente proprio un rimedio
contro la febbre incredibile sto gioco
che lo consiglio giocateci o sui tre
ragazzi se il video è piaciuta sul
momento è un mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e come intende description solo
city ci vediamo non fossimo vito bella
ragazzi